latest medical news on the pandemic
crisis were joined by CBS News medical
contributor dr. David agus dr. good
morning the majority of the country
beginning to reopen now we're seeing New
York City is now on track so as we reach
this stage right now how do prevention
methods change our our facial coverings
still an effective tool no question
about it this is a droplet spread
disease-- wearing masks in public will
dramatically decrease the spread of the
virus from one person to another it has
to be done we all have to think of one
here and where mass it's simple okay
doctor there is a there is some news
that's coming out about corona virus as
it relates to pre-existing health
conditions it affects people who have
those conditions obviously more there is
new research on cancer this morning
urine oncologist tell us about that and
how much are concerned so this is the
largest study down there two studies
done one in Europe and one here in the
United States and what it showed was is
that people who had cancer active cancer
and were diagnosed with Kovan 19 in a 30
day period there was almost a 13% death
rate in those people 13% death rate so
cancer was a significant risk for
complications and death from copa90 what
was interesting in this study is it
didn't matter if you were actively
receiving treatment or not so the
take-home is be aware if you have cancer
and continue treatment to try to get
that cancer under control David we heard
the president Trump yesterday announced
that the US will cut ties with the w-h-o
we're in the middle of a pandemic what
are the potential repercussions of that
listen I've been as critical as anybody
over the World Health Organization over
the last several decades its
bureaucratic it's slow to act but we
need it at this time this is a global
pandemic and there is one organization
that can organize member countries
across the globe to work together to
share data to make the right things
happen for the betterment of humankind
and so I don't think this is the right
time to walk out of the World Health
Organization on the vaccine side news
about a possible need to do human
challenge trials explain what those are
so challenge trials we've done before
with the common cold which is we give
you a vaccine and then we wait several
weeks later and we actually give you the
virus you know now that numbers are
decreasing of the virus across the globe
if you do a clinical trial it may take a
long time to get enough patients with
them without the virus to know the
answer but with a challenge trial and
there are risks believe me you're giving
the riders to people but you can very
quickly know whether a vaccine works or
not this is something that is being
discussed both here in the United States
and around the world as a possibility of
a way to accelerate vaccine development
yeah time is obviously of the essence
right now dr. David agus as always thank
you